it's very raw so Rob that you don't
think you can do as well as it can if we
do something else when you correct now I
don't think we need 45-minute I think
you're wrong okay we do what you are
saying all the time you have to have an
off-speed pitch to set up your fastball
even if the project doesn't succeed it's
a success guys this is amazing you
understand it so I for sure don't think
it's gonna go viral no no I'm just
talking I can't wait to hear it and he
says I want it this way because I think
of things as a holistic thing not in the
silo words great guess what you just
[ __ ] record it at again ya know so
dear [ __ ] fans do you want these 11
tracks do they definitely definitely
videos yes we're on video audio and the
written word I listen I totally get it
if you think of it in the micro I think
the macro of it is what helps the
overall that's what we do right now
we're talking basically he's like some
of it's hard to watch
just busier for me I was like that's
interesting nobody has ever seen that
from Matt's wife like that's that's how
it was like that's his whole theory
about everything great news squee news
literally hey everybody that's how we
thought about launching this project
here's your intro to the [ __ ] plane
project I hope you enjoy it
that's meta from the second week from
the beginning that's all I want